deux choix c'est un terme qui est clair
pour vous c'est bon vous l'avez bien vu
en quoi shoah camps d'internement
solution finale le génocide des juifs il
expliqué à ces collégiens du cher devant
l'une des baraques du camp de
beaune-la-rolande ce jour là ils suivent
le parcours organisé par le centre
d'études et de recherche sur les camps
d'internement du loiret ceci notamment
au prince et par des histoires des vies
des histoires de famille si bien des
enfants que les hommes et des femmes qui
sont passés par parcequ'en quelquefois
étaient plus jeunes que vous avez le
ménage en racontant leur histoire ils
peuvent comme ça comparez se rendent
compte pas bien non plus identifié en
fait à ces personnes et c'est ce qui
leur arrive et la tragédie de cette
histoire première étape sur les traces
de leur persécution à orléans à l'image
de l'ancienne synagogue endommagés sous
l'occupation allemande
les miliciens se sont les sondés
français qui sont d'accord avec le
maréchal pétain qui sont opposés aux
alliés qui sont d'accord politiquement
avec les nazis qui vont traquer les
résistants et les juifs
photos à l'appui les élèves remonte le
temps c'est pas que des photos c'est on
le voit vraiment on est vraiment là où
ils ont été faits choquants d'un pays
comme nous on penserait pas que c'est
l'histoire de notre pays direction
ensuite l'ancienne gare de pithiviers où
seize mille juifs transitaires entre
1941 et 1943 avant d'être déportée à
auschwitz en pologne
c'est vraiment depuis cette gare depuis
ces quelques les trains sont partis en
direction de jose pour les enseignants
ces visites représente le moyen de
préserver la mémoire de la déportation
maintenant on arrive à une génération
dont les grands parents étaient très
petit pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
voire pas né et c'est vrai que quand je
leur demande en classe vos grands
parents en ont déjà parlé j'ai presque
plus de réponses alors qu'il ya encore
quelques années il y avait des échanges
d'anecdotes ou d'objets dévoila des
héritages d'objets qui se faisait ses je
trouve que c'est en train de s'amenuiser
pour faire perdurer la mémoire des camps
d'internement du loiret le cercil
intervient régulièrement dans les écoles
de pithiviers et beaune-la-rolande et
mon invité ce soir et annaïck lefeuvre
responsable du cercil
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous on vient
de suivre cette visite scolaire
notamment dans votre établissement on
coince est important 76 ans après la
libération des comptes de perpétuer ce
travail de mémoire
eh bien c'est la mission du cercil c'est
un centre d'histoire et de mémoire qui
mène des recherches depuis 30 ans le
point d'entrée c'est l'histoire des
camps d'internement du loiret et ce
c'étaient là des élèves de la région
d'ailleurs qui étaient là donc qui
découvre à partir de lieux qui leur sont
proches
une histoire pour laquelle il y a en
fait beaucoup de représentations
aujourd'hui ils ont beaucoup de deux
films de livres qu'ils peuvent voir mais
reste à faire le travail d'histoire
effectivement pour comprendre le
processus pour comprendre ce qu'a été un
camp d'internement pour comprendre ce
qui a été un camp dans la france
collaborationniste ce qu'a été le régime
de vichy et ce qu'est un processus
génocidaire donc vous voyez qu'il ya
plusieurs niveaux d'échelle et on a
entendu justement dont le sujet cette
enseignante expliqué que parmi ses
élèves il y avait de moins en moins deux
témoignages directs du grand parents qui
n'avaient pas forcément connu la guerre
est ce que ça vous inquiète cette
mémoire vivante qui s'étend au fil du
temps de fêtes
de fait en avançant dans le temps on
s'éloigne du passé
on ne peut pas changer l'histoire mais
on peut l'analyser et donc c'est ce que
les il faut s'appuyer sur les sources
historiques
c'est pour ça que c'est important que
les élèves qui n'ont pas le temps dans
le temps scolaire de comprendre toute la
complexité de ce sujet de de se
confronter à des archives et à des
sources historiques et qu'ils aient un
point d'ancrage et des référents pour
les un point de repère effectivement
historique
alors cette année 2021 elles marquent
deux anniversaires d'abord les dix ans
de la création du musée mais aussi les
30 ans du cercil
le centre d'étude et de recherche sur
les camps d'internement du loiret il a
été créé à l'initiative de familles de
déportés en 91 et notamment d' hélène
mouchard zay la fille du ministre jean
zay assassiné par la milice de vichy en
44 on regarde ce sujet de corinne bien
rosa et charlie krief et on se retrouve
juste après avec notre invité
elle s'appelle aline et elle est le
visage du cercil gazée à auschwitz le
jour de ses trois ans elle est le visage
de ses quatre mille quatre cents enfants
juifs internés dans les camps de beaune
la rolande et pithiviers puis déporté
pas un seul n'est revenu
faire émerger cette vérité a été un des
combats d'hélène mouchard zay ces
événements étaient ignorées donc mais
pourquoi on m'a dit mais pourquoi
rappeler maintenant pourquoi rappeler
ces événements on me disait il faut
tourner la page et moi ce à quoi je
réponds tu es je veux bien tourné la
page et encore tout dépend de la façon
dont on la tourne c'est pas d'oubli
tourner une page se rappeler en mémoire
ce qu'on a lu mais il faut d'abord la
lyre donc il faut faire ce travail qui
n'a pas été fait de rappeler de faire
une exposition de faire des publications
il faut absolument rappeler ces
événements 50 ans après ou pas il faut
le faire
les mille mètres carrés de l'ancienne
école orléanaise devenu le musée du
cercil raconte l'histoire de ces camps
de la honte comme on les appelait les
murs résonnent du témoignage d'annette
müller seul enfant rescapé avec son
petit frère
elle avait 9 ans
on avait tout cela dysenterie des
boutons des la tête rasée des étoiles
jaunes peintes sur les vêtements on
était comme un comme du bétail et les
gens nous regardaient à mon avis je
sentais un dégoût de la part des gens il
ya la grande histoire mais la micro ce
qu'on appelle ami trop souvent la petite
histoire c'est ça qui va amener les
jeunes à prendre conscience de la
réalité des jeux sinon 6 millions de
morts qu'est ce que ça dit à des jeunes
surtout presque enfin 80 ça près mais ce
qui leur dit c'est que comme le dit
d'ailleurs toujours carte fel la shoah
c'est sémillant mort mais c'est un peu
ça il y a dix ans simone veil et jacques
chirac étaient là pour l'inauguration du
musée
signe que les temps avaient changé même
si aujourd'hui le devoir d'histoire et
le travail de mémoire s'avère toujours
indispensable un igloo favre on
entendait dans ce sujet le témoignage
très fort un d'hélène mouchard zay sur
le déni qui a très longtemps existé sur
les cons l'existence des camps
d'internement dans le loiret ils ont été
découverts dans les années 90 au début
des années 90 comment se fait-il que ça
a été oubliée alors c'est pas simplement
pour l'histoire des camps d'internement
du loiret mais on va justement dans une
exposition restituer un peu une histoire
de la mémoire locale nationale et c'est
vrai qu'elle a new jersey le dit en 1990
il y à une urgence l'exposition
s'appellera sortir de l'oubli parce que
mais elle le dit très bien tout le monde
voulait tourner la page
et elle le rappelle encore faut-il la
regarder donc il y a trente ans c'est
vraiment un moment où émerger une
nouvelle mémoire de la shoah et où on
était avant la reconnaissance des crimes
de vichy un dernier mot je le disais
tout à l'heure ce lundi débute la
semaine d'action de lutte contre le
racisme et l'antisémitisme dans notre
société d'aujourd'hui qu'elles devraient
être selon vous le bon discours pour
lutter contre ce type de violences en
alors je sais pas s'il faut aller
directement au discours
parce que à vouloir aller directement
aux messages peut-être qu'on oublie une
étape essentielle qui est celle de
l'histoire et c'est justement le temps
qu'on essaye de prendre dans un musée
mémorial c'est à dire le temps de
l'analyse pour refroidir un petit peu
des questions vives qui circulent via
les réseaux sociaux avec certains
discours qui ne permettent pas forcément
de prendre la mesure de certains
événements et d'en comprendre les enjeux
même pour le temps présent
effectivement prendre le temps prendre
le temps de réfléchir et de regarder le
passé merci beaucoup annaïg lefeuvre a
d'être venu son plateau du 19-20 centre
val de loire ce soir